[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
Twitter's dead I mean it's been dead
X really you're gonna you're gonna go
with a symbol of fascism
bigotry the stars and bars
okay all right all right well that
sounds that sounds about right Elon not
only is gonna kill Twitter
he's gonna stomp it into the ground and
make sure it's really dead
this is dumb you paid 44 billion dollars
for a brand literally a brand and now
you're like yeah I don't like that no
more
that's not manly enough that's not
that's not that doesn't have the fascist
undertones that I want enough
and he started to Rebrand on Twitter
it's still blue
like they're still using the color blue
on on the website you're gonna see it
today I'll show it to you in screenshots
here on the show and so if you're
listening on the audio version
you know you're gonna have to come over
and watch it on YouTube to see the how
he's branded it with this x someone
pointed out I forgot who it was
someone someone pointed out that it was
uh
that it looks like a razor blade cutting
a a line of cocaine
there's all sorts of uh um submissions
that were
done to Elon for the for the logo X
I don't know I I think I think it's
signaling exactly what he wants he
doesn't he doesn't want it to be a
welcoming website he wants it to be uh
the ability for him to charge you to be
his fan like literally I think that's
what he's going for here
I'm gonna charge you eight dollars to be
my fan and and some people are saying he
wants it and Gabe's talked about this
extensively uh on this on the show and
that he wants to make it um and I forget
what the uh app is in China but there's
an app in China that's all encompassing
right it it's a banking app it's a
social media app everybody what what
Gabe calls it or what they call it and
Gabe's mentioned it here on the show but
he wants to make it the biggest banking
app in the world like would I would
never give Elon my [__] bank account
information that's one of the reasons
why I haven't
that I haven't got a Twitter blue
account there are some advantages like
you can edit your tweets which a lot of
people like
if you're a blue check you can edit them
or you can post longer videos than like
two minutes
which is kind of cool
and but it's not worth eight bucks and
it's definitely not worth giving Elon
Musk my [__] banking information [__]
you no way and the minute that Twitter
I'm not gonna call it X by the way
Twitter requires us to give them I I
have to give them my banking information
I have a [__] account [__] you I'm
gone
[__] you now I'm not doing that [__] I
am not giving Elon Musk my banking
information you can go [__] yourself
with with the obvious insecurity that
goes with
Twitter I I wouldn't even say certain
things in DMS anymore
[__] no hell no
Hills to the no
there's no telling what that [__]
piece of [__] will do with my
information
right I mean you trust Elon with your
with your banking information
because that's what you're doing if you
give it to Twitter you're trusting him
personally
it doesn't feel like it that much but it
really truly is that and you're trusting
him personally
hmm
a great show for you today I got
Tennessee Brando coming on
that's right Tennessee Brando is going
to join us I've uh I played several of
his songs that he's written recently
just in the past few months but the best
one I think that I like a lot is
Hunter's hard on uh where he talks about
how the Republicans are absolutely
obsessed with Hunter Biden's
right
um
oh boy you can't make this [__] up it
just makes itself up really along the
way is the stupid timeline that we're in
speaking it's and he's going to talk
about his music okay he's going to talk
about his music he's gonna he's gonna
talk about how he I want to ask him how
he how he makes the music how he comes
up with the songs how quickly because it
seems like man he can get these songs
going so I don't know if it's like this
inspiration of an idea in his head that
pops in that makes him such a quick
songwriter but he gets to it quick right
he gets to these songs quick and he's
got a new one out um maybe we'll listen
to it too and the audience hasn't heard
it yet here on the show it's called the
Barbie and Ben it's about Ben Shapiro
Obsession uh with Barbie and then the
Barbie movie and we're going to talk
about that today too I went to see
Barbie that's right I went to see Barbie
not because I wanted to have outrage
about Barbie I didn't buy a bunch of
Barbies and burn them I just went and
seen the movie but I have a good story
for you at the end of the movie oh man
it's wild stuff
um
I have a story about being in the
theater
whoo something else so I'll tell you my
um Barbie movie story today and Gabe
Sanchez is going to join us at the top
of the hour Tennessee Brando is going to
be here at the bottom of the hour so
don't go anywhere you're not go anywhere
this is a two-hour show that you're not
gonna want to miss also I'm gonna ask uh
Tennessee Brenda why he's here
uh about the Jason Aldean situation I
know he's a country music fan and I know
I know Tennessee Brando knows the
history of country music he knows a lot
about country music
um so we're going to ask him about Jason
Aldean in his Jason Aldean actually
country music I don't think he actually
is
um but we're gonna we're gonna lay some
of the other [__] aside and we're just
gonna talk about country music as a
whole because I think a lot of people
get confused I mean you cannot like
country music but if you think country
music is inherently racist then I think
you're off track you don't know the
history of folk and country music so
maybe Tennessee Brando can give us um
some words on why it's not I also have a
clip uh to play for Tennessee Brando of
Willie Nelson
The Godfather of country music right now
basically country and folk music uh
Willie Nelson Willie Nelson apparently
doing a show over the weekend
absolutely trashing Jason Aldean on
stage with his [__] guitar as Woody
Guthrie say the machine that kills
fascism
hmm seems like there's something to this
Falcon country that's against fascism
seems like it I don't know maybe I'm
wrong
maybe you should where I can do some do
some studying on what the history of
country music is that'll help maybe
maybe that'll help
I don't know any hoot so we're gonna
have tendency Miranda on we're gonna
talk to him and we're going to talk
about today the Barbie movie but I'm
also gonna keep track of these
indictments right uh rather the
indictments fall this week I actually I
don't know if they're gonna get two
indictments this week if we look at the
last federal indictments against Donald
Trump when he receive the target letter
it was almost three weeks after
um he received the target letter that he
actually was indicted so and they're
apparently they're they're interviewing
Witnesses with the grand jury this week
and next week I think so it doesn't look
like the indictments are going to come
uh this week maybe next week maybe the
week after but they're ready to strike I
I believe that Jack Smith has enough
information and enough enough evidence
to indict him on God knows how many
[__] charges and what the charges are
exactly but I I do believe that Jack
Smith is going to make sure he has every
single piece of information before he
does now with these federal indictments
what you have to understand is that a
lot of times uh federal indictments do
first sweeping indictments and then they
do superseding indictments now I'm no
[__] lawyer you know that but I I
know this stuff
um here's the thing super seating
indictments can do one or two things
they can either rope in new uh new
people who are indicted so new new
co-defendants on the indictment or it
can give new charges so that's what you
have to understand about what the
federal system does whether it's with
the documents case of the January 6 case
uh you're gonna see the original
indictments and then possible
superseding indictments which will rope
in either other people or more charges
but the thing I really want to know the
thing I'm dying to know about this
indictment because what is he up to is
it 34
uh felonies in New York and it's 37 in
Florida right
ah so we're at 71 right am I right am I
right on the map am I right on that math
I I think I'm right on that math so it's
like 71 indictments if he gets over 30
indictments for uh charges felony
charges for the January 6 coup attempt
he's gonna have over a hundred
indictments this is really important I
know you're like Tony is it really
important the number you [__] ain't
right it is and the reason why it's so
important the number is because of the
messaging okay this is super this is
super super important uh when you go out
into the world you say You're Gonna vote
for a guy that has over 100 felony
felony charges on him a hundred hundred
hundred sounds like a lot a hundred and
over a thousand people have convicted to
help him with the coup attempt that he's
charged for that's the thing that's the
narrative that's the collective piece
you know hey here at the Tony Michaels 5
case I Ivy Tony Michaels am not shy to
politicize issues you know that I will
politicize the [__] out of something and
let me tell you something if this guy
has over 100 felonies that's beautiful
that's really easy messaging this guy's
got over 100 felonies 100 100 sounds so
sounds so even it sounds so big it
sounds so serious when you have a
hundred felony charges against you
that's a lot by the way
I I would almost bet that there's very
few people in history
that have actually had a hundred felony
charges against them all at one time
that's a lot of [__] charges folks
you got to be a damn big criminal to
have over 100 felony charges against you
I'm not [__] you go back and you
just just look it up just look up how
many people how many
defendants have had over a hundred
felony charges against them in the
history in this country there ain't
going to be too damn many and he's the
first president to have over a hundred
felon he charges against him oh boy he's
gonna go down in the history books and
we're going to make sure of it and
that's the messaging that's the
narrative over a thousand people have
been convicted
of helping him overturn our government
and now he's gonna have over a hundred
felony charges so I really I'm rooting
for 30 40 felonies here that's what I'm
rooting for that's what I'm rooting for
it's 30 40 felony charges here in the
January 6 case and I think Jack Smith
can get there
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure uh
Donald Trump was criming his ass off
so I'm I'm pretty well um set that he's
gonna get
dozens dozens of new indictments uh so
be looking for that I think I think I
don't think it's gonna happen this week
course I've been wrong before
about when he's going to get indicted to
win the indictments will come down I
figured Jack Smith would wait for the
documents indictments uh while he did
the January 6 because it's been so close
but obviously Jack Smith is willing uh
to charge and to prosecute these crimes
separately
which is only a signal that Donald Trump
isn't didn't just commit one act of
crime he's criming all the time and
climbing right out in the open
and so so we'll we will find out we will
find out as the days take on and again
if we look back at the last indictment
of Jack Smith or the last indictment
Jack Smith brought to Donald Trump's
table
um it was several weeks after the target
letter
and he kind of did the same thing right
so he sent him a Target letter for the
documents case we found that out and
then and then he interviewed a few more
witnesses and then they indicted which
it seems like that's what they're doing
here they know they have enough evidence
they know they're going to indict him
um they know it's going to be under seal
for a bit so they're going to
until he's actually arraigned so they're
they're going to float this letter to
him to give him the chance to wrap up
their investigation of these Witnesses
and then they're gonna
um
slam the hammer down on him the other
question that I have about the
indictments is who is going to be on
this January 6 indictment with them Rudy
Giuliani uh where we see Mark Meadows
where we see uh John Eastman uh Jeffrey
Clark there's a lot of uh unanswered
questions of who will be on this
indictment ASCO co-conspirators and
co-defendants now the other indictment
that's that's soon to be coming we're
going to get to 100 [__] charges here
folks there's no way he's not going to
have 100 felonies no [__] way no
[__] way with with Jack Smith and DC
and Bonnie Willis and the Fulton The
Fulton County D.A in Georgia there's no
way this guy's not going to have 100
[__] felonies
and they're they're still going to be
like yeah that's the guy we want
he's our Criminal
oh yeah a lot of people a lot of people
are getting worried too and as it looks
like Ron DeSantis is drowning in his in
his own wokeness or his own message of
witness have you seen this Vivek Rama
Swami
in a Fox News poll I think that's what
it was a Fox News poll I don't know I
don't pay attention to the polls they're
all [__] anyways they're just
they're [__] rigged they're rigged
they're lies they're you know I am in a
good sample polls suck nowadays they
need to change the way they do polls and
maybe they'll have a decent one and
they'll start believing them but until
then I just think it's all [__] but
here's the thing if you don't think it's
[__] and you want to politicize
something which I definitely do want to
politicize something Vivek ramaswami is
now tied with Ron DeSantis at 14
so vivec and I called it I called it and
I'd hate to say I told you so but you
can just doubt me all you want all you
want you can doubt me and I'll
that how many times did I tell you on
this show that Vivek Rama Swami
was Trump is a trump plant to make him
the number two
what did what did I say what did I tell
you I've been telling you this for
months
so you can get mad at me that I'm right
99 of the time or you can just start
believing me 99 of the time I don't know
what to tell you but Vivek Rama Swami
embarrassing Ron DeSantis which we knew
this was going to happen I told you this
was going to happen I told Rhonda santis
buddy when he when when Trump got
indicted in New York I said Ron get out
in front of a microphone right now
resign as governor and run for president
he would have I think he could have take
taken the top spot then he waited way
too long see that's what Ron does he's
such a [__] pussy-ass [__] Ron he is
he really is he [__] foots around he
doesn't really do what he's supposed to
do get Ron just [__] or get off the pot
okay either run or don't run or don't
now he thought he was gonna be a big
game when he had big money
right but he spent like 15 million
dollars and didn't move a [__] inch
in these dumbass polls that they have
didn't move an inch and then when Trump
got indicted twice he still didn't move
and the reason why is because Ron
DeSantis is weak and it's not surprising
that he's weak in his presidential
campaign because he's a weak little
fascist down in Florida
so much so that he's so [__] weak he
has to Pander to white people in Florida
that oh we can't we can't teach white
people what slavery really was they'll
be offended they'll be guilty it gives a
[__] listen if you feel guilt over
slavery because because someone tells
you the truth about it of what white
people did the black people in this
country if you feel guilt over that
personally then there's you need to do a
self-evaluation okay you need to do a
self-evaluation if the truth hurts your
[__] feelings that goddamn much
speaking of Truth and hurting feelings
Jason Aldean
oh he he's so upset that they tried to
cancel him
they just don't know what his message is
we all know what his message is I know
what his [__] messages I know who
he's singing to
but I I have a great clip I'm not gonna
I might show you the Jason Aldean clip
where he's crying on stage boohooing to
himself what a [__] what a pansy now
I'm gonna show you a clip of a real
country music artist
Willie Nelson and Tennessee Randall is
going to join us here in just about 10
minutes
and I'm going to show him too this clip
of Willa Nelson absolutely wanting Jason
Aldean up into a little spitball and
tossing him into the [__] garbage it
is [__] fantastic and the best part
about it is Willie Nelson does it again
with what Woody Guthrie would say a
machine that kills fascism he sings a
song that's right Willie said [__] that
[__] I ain't gonna talk about it I'm
gonna sing about a [__] and that's what
will Nelson does because that's what
country music is that's what folk music
is and Willie Nelson knows it and Willie
Nelson knows that Jason Aldean ain't
gonna [__] with no Willie Nelson
I would love to see that wouldn't you oh
my God I would love to see Jason Aldean
try to say something cross about the
Godfather right now of Falcon country
music the one of the greatest
songwriters of all time Willie Nelson
when Jason Aldean that ugly [__]
can't even write his own song
so we're going to talk about that with
Tennessee Brando
oh boy oh boy oh boy I had big news
yesterday on the patreon for those who
joined us we're going to start a new
project over on patreon I'm very excited
about it and I'm very excited that that
that the audience is excited about it
and some of them that were there
yesterday on the patreon will tell you
about this project that we're doing it's
we're calling it right now we're calling
it The Round Table of democracy and I
and I I love this idea and I thought how
could we make this possible and I know a
lot of organizations do something like
this but you guys I tell you every day
engage in your democracy engage in it in
real life online wherever you can
whatever your talents tell you to do to
engage in your democracy do that we have
someone today on the show that engages
in his democracy with his talents his
name is Tennessee Brando I'm excited to
talk to him about that and that's what
brings up this whole idea of what you
can do the audience member yes you I'm
talking to you if you're listening to
this what you can do to engage in your
democracy I know you have a talent I
have really shitty handwriting I can't
write postcards and letters no one could
read it but you might have really good
handwriting you might be really good at
making telephone calls or doing text
messages you might be really good with
people face to face
you might be really good at something in
democracy that you didn't even know you
had the skills and the ability to do you
might not even know that it exists and
that's what this round table of
democracy is designed to do and I am so
excited that people are excited about
this that we're going to work on this
together now if you're a member of the
patreon uh last night if you joined us
it's going to be it's going to be kind
of like workshops and tutorials we're
going to seek out information because
that's one thing we don't have amongst
us here on the audience is one place we
can go to to tap into how we can engage
because I tell you how to get to engage
all the time but I've never given you
the tools to engage so I thought well
why not just get everyone together the
[__] them fam the audience is so smart
you guys are so talented we have small
rats making videos we have people making
memes we have Edward tweeting from the
Pod account
we we have Mighty librarian giving us
directions online of how to do things
how to work social media so I think we
can do this together right I'm really
good at one thing yelling and screaming
into a microphone I don't know if you
noticed but I can talk a lot so that's
what my talent is and that's what I
contribute
and I think with my platform that I can
use it for more influence of more good
and what that means is to show you give
you the tools to engage now I'm no
expert in all these subjects so what
should I do what I should do is get us
all together and find someone that is
good at this topic and good at this
thing maybe they're good at registering
voters in this state maybe this person's
really good at making phone calls to the
representatives whether it be state or
federal Representatives maybe they're
really good at that and they know a lot
about it we could bring them on get
everything we need to know about them in
a small little piece of content
and then what we can do is we can post
it online oh baby this is where it gets
really good we post it online on a
website
and then that website lives forever it
lives forever and we've got now until
November to develop maybe 20 30
workshops where you can engage in your
democracy and I can give you this little
website and say here go find the one
that fits you learn about it study it
find the information and engage in your
democracy because I think sometimes when
I say engage in your democracy people
are like Ah that's all talk that's just
Tony talking well we're gonna take
action that's what we're gonna do and
we're going to compile all these pieces
of information find them seek them out
and provide them for you for the
audience so that you can engage your
democracy and we're gonna we're gonna
start to do that on the patreon so if
you want if you're interested in helping
develop
this piece of this project this round
table of democracy that's what we're
calling it that's just the the starting
name Round Table of democracy we might
change it
I don't know I don't know maybe we'll
change the logo maybe we'll steal the
old bird logo maybe we'll make it the
bird logo now now that he's scrapped it
maybe we'll we'll what a [__] idiot
change Twitter to X ah Jesus Christ
anyways so if you're interested in in
participating on the Roundtable
democracy go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com click the
patreon link and we'll be talking about
that more over there this week in the
coming weeks of what we're going to do I
don't even know exactly what it's going
to be that's the beauty of a piece of
content like this and and a an
organization of information like this is
you never know how it's going to turn
out but we need your help and we need
your help uh on compiling this
information giving us ideas giving us
feedback and let's all work together and
I really think we can gauge in democracy
together so go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com click the
patreon link there
boy oh boy oh boy what a good show I
can't wait to talk to Tennessee Brando
here
um about uh country music something look
I grew up on country music it is
something that is near and dear to my
heart
I remember so many artists so many songs
and I I love Gold Country and I love
Prime Country Gold Country is you know
60s 70s some 80s 80s and 90s is prime
country I don't really like the pop
country as much these days but that's
just my ears right that's my ears liking
a certain type of music
um but I I've noticed in the comments
and when we get Tennessee Brando on here
uh he's I think he has the same
sentiment is that we've seen a lot of
comments that say well country music is
just you know racist redneck hillbilly
music anyways and that's not exactly the
truth that's not the history of country
music and and I'd like to talk to
Tennessee Brandon but I also want to ask
him about
uh how he develops his songs and how
could he man he pumps him out quick then
he something happens he gets inspired
boom there's a song something else
happens some some fascists online is
losing their mind about something boom
there's a song
or a fascist in Congress is flashing
porn boom there's the song There's a
song and so he gets inspired by these
and I can't wait to talk to him and I
hope we can have him on the show more
often I'm super excited to have him here
so don't don't go anywhere don't go
anywhere stick around
we're gonna be right back with Tennessee
Brando right after this
[Music]
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott finder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
if you're on YouTube right now get your
ass down there and like
thumbs up button or put the thumbs down
I don't give a [__] if you don't like
the show put a thumbs down just keep
watching we might change your mind it's
got a great guest coming up so you might
change your mind but if you're on the
YouTube channel right now subscribe
Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube hit the
like button you know also if you if you
want to watch this show in different
places you can also watch it on Facebook
just go to Tony Michaels at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook that's at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook don't forget to
follow me over there
on Twitter that's right I said it
Twitter I'm not calling it whatever the
hell he wants me to call it I'm gonna
call it what I want to call it on
Twitter you can follow us at Tony
Michaels pod as as long as I'm still
over there he starts wanting my bank
account information Elon can go get
[__] as far as I'm concerned so we'll
see you can also watch us on Twitch
follow us on Twitch for free twitch.tv
slash D Tony Michaels that's twitch.tv
Tony Michaels follow us for free if you
have an Amazon Prime account and you
have it linked to your Twitch account
and you give us that one free
subscription every month
you know what I'm talking about if you
do that make sure you resubscribe
every single month so if you haven't
done it in a while go re-subscribe
and to our Twitch account with your
Amazon Prime account you can link the
two and then you re-subscribe every
month just go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com the
directions are right there they're the
fourth one down on how to link your
account and then how to resubscribe is
also in the directions
so go to the Tony michaels.com to figure
out how to link those two to give us
monetary support that doesn't cost you
any extra money because if you have an
Amazon Prime account it doesn't cost you
a single dime to give us that monetary
support kind of a cool thing
anyways anywho we got a great guest
today and I don't want to waste too much
time getting to this guest he's he's a
great artist he's a great songwriter we
played his songs here on the show before
uh and again he's so quick to the guitar
he's so quick to the lyrics and really
they they do the situations right
themselves because these people are so
ridiculous right they're really they're
really parodies and satire of themselves
but how fast he gets to it and the
lyrics he's right are just phenomenal so
that's why I wanted to have him on the
show and hopefully we'd hand back more
and more and more Tennessee Brando
welcome to the Tony Michaels podcast how
are you my friend hey man I'm doing
really good good to see you hey good to
see you too good to see you too I played
several your songs on the show before
and I appreciate it yeah well last week
you You released um hard on hard on for
Hunter I believe is what it's called and
I played it for the audience and they
they absolutely loved it and I was like
you know what I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna see if he'll come on and talk
about how he writes these songs and in
the meantime by the time I said come on
the show and you're like yeah I'll come
on the show you wrote another one about
Barbie and Ben Shapiro so yeah um I I
can't I can't figure out which one I
want to play for the audience here but
the one thing I want to ask you is
how what what gives you these kernels of
inspiration do these words just like pop
into your mind or does it take a while
or how do you how do you write these
songs because I know the audience is
interested in that well to tell you the
truth you know I've been writing songs
for years uh but I started uh recording
my music at a place called Arbor studio
in Knoxville Tennessee about around 2015
and
um the the producer and owner of the
studio there John Baker he does a thing
called this it's a songpoint project
where a friend of his has students who
write poems and then they hand them to
to the musicians in Knoxville and we try
to just when John told us he said look
he said don't think about this because
we've got a whole bunch of them
sometimes he would have 70 to 100
different oh wow holy [__] so it would
be like okay just just read these lyrics
and put them to music as fast as you can
you know just get them there because we
got to get this done so it's almost like
speed songwriting yeah well that
exercise I I participated in that and
then I just kind of adopted that over
into my own songwriting because once you
do it it it's it's easy so like like
take the song uh you talk about hard on
for Hunter I see that I find it funny a
lot of times like that line I caught
myself saying man she's got a hard on
for Hunter and then boom you know now
it's like okay so I grabbed my guitar
the very first chord I hit is going to
be at I'm not even gonna think about it
just whatever key I hit that's it we're
gonna work in the kids whichever it's
yeah I don't even remember AEG whatever
so so basically basically it's just just
run with it just run with it and don't
think about it just just let it go
because uh you know like you said a
minute ago the songs right themselves
there's there's right so they're so
ridiculous they're so ridiculous and
over the top that you really just have
to there's times I may catch a few
little key points in my head like oh I
want to mention what this part or
whatever but uh I I think that
songwriting process working with John
helped me to adopt it over to this music
and and with this music you got to be
fast because a lot of these topics they
come and go so fast and they're
happening so fast that if you pause and
wait a few weeks before you talk about
it you've already missed the account
conversation right right well you know
we we played we played hard on for
Hunter and I listened again this morning
to um uh uh Barbie and Ben I think is
the what the song title is yeah the
legend of Barbie yeah the legend of
that's what it is the legend of Barbie
and so I want to play that one for the
audience here real quick if you don't
mind so they can get a sense so they can
get a sense of your your music here uh
and again this is a brand new one uh
from Tennessee Brando here it's called
The Legend of Barbie and Ben well Ben
Shapiro went to the movies to watch
Barbie and he's pretty upset about it so
I figured I'd write this too and try to
cheer him up I call it the legend of
Barbie and Ben
[Music]
headed down to the Picture Show
sit there red face and white nuggets
it's a little ahead about to explode
surrounded by those middle Edge mamas
shaking like a leaf and scared to death
what's he to do with all the madness
when Lord knows he can't get him with
[Music]
sure has crossed the line trans Barbie
she drove him out of his mind
set therapy
now again and so goes the legend of
Barbie
screaming boycott he gotta get a handle
on all of this far left Chinese
propaganda he burned all his Barbies
with her Jeep and cans and so does the
legend of Barbie
Barbie
[Music]
perfect perfect he couldn't get any
better than that
so so that's you're really quick on it
when something happens like that of
course you know Ben Shapiro paid money
he paid money to go see the movie and
then he paid money to destroy Barbies
which is
kind of telling about you know how much
he actually hates Barbie I think it's
more about how he can get his audience
outraged at women
um exactly then he hates Barbie but
you're quick on the draw and you're
quick on the song now I wanna I wanna I
wanna tell you something I watch your
videos and I'm I'm looking at your
background there and there's a photo of
a guy one of the greatest songwriters
that I know and I love him and a lot of
people don't know John Prine and they
don't know a lot about John Prine but it
brings me to yeah that's John Prine
right there yeah
John Prine is a a full uh music
songwriter great musician
um we lost him to covid I was actually
going to go see John Prine in Columbia
Missouri at roots and blues I believe no
no we were gonna go see him we were
gonna go see him in um I think St Louis
we were going to go see a concert and he
got sick and he had to cancel the
concert so I've never actually seen John
um live which is uh you know
heartbreaking because I I really wish I
had that experience to say I saw John
Prine live but that brings me to the
next topic I want to talk about because
everyone's talking about this Jason
Aldean song I've talked about it I
actually avoided talking about it at
first because I was like oh this is
going to blow over no one gives a [__]
about this guy not not only is he not a
good singer he doesn't write his own
songs and he's an ugly son of a [__]
right he's not even he's not even good
looking for crying out loud so here's
the here's the thing is that um a lot of
people get in comments about this Jason
Aldean and they say well all country
music is racist it's rooted in racism
and folk music is the is the foundation
of country music and folk music is
anything but anything but
um elitist or against the the poor it's
actually to describe the plight of the
poor in this country John Prine did such
a good job of using his using his
machine that kills fascism his guitar
Woody Guthrie did and others um and I
want to play a clip for you real quick
to one of the uh one of the high women
who's still alive and I saw someone post
a picture of The Highwaymen and Kris
Kristofferson Johnny Cash and Willie
Nelson and they said all these guys are
all racist I'm like what the what the
[__] listen you're not listening to
their music then you haven't listened to
this the words they've written and the
things they've said and the things
they've sang but this is Willie uh here
uh any and well let's well let's just
play it kind of speaks for itself don't
you know what the whole thing's about
[Music]
your ass so far I bet you can't pull it
out
[Music]
and the world gets smaller
everyone
[Music]
why don't you write your own song
[Applause]
that might run you crazy
[Music]
it might make you dwell on your feelings
I'm almost too long
now when you have a real artist uh like
Willie Nelson you don't need you don't
need big fancy marketing campaigns big
fancy ploys and stunts where you make a
song with shitty lyrics shitty music you
have someone like Jason Aldean you can't
sing worth the [__] sing it and it's not
catchy it's not even objectively a good
song and then you put it to a racist
video you don't need to do stunts like
that you can just do art you just do art
you can just sing about the things that
you know to sing about and that's who
will Nelson is and that's what country
music is and I know a lot of people may
not like country music as a whole
but you know the history of country
music so tell the audience the things
that you know about country music and
the thing does that tell you that Jason
Aldean is not country music
yeah I'm glad you brought this up
because uh it's been an argument that
I've been having for years before I
started doing this political satire
style of songwriting you know I was I
was writing my own songs about you know
the part of the world I grew up in which
is I'm from east Tennessee Southeast
Kentucky I'm right on the border and so
I grew up in Kentucky and lived in
Tennessee now but uh you know I wrote a
lot about the things that people in
Appalachia struggle with every day and
there's a whole lot of people out there
that you know would come out to my
shelves to watch me play that would that
would count me Outlaw country and it
wasn't like I tried to necessarily ride
on that Banner or claim to be that but
but what I'm trying to say is those
people hated Jason Aldean they couldn't
stand him they hated Jason Aldean Luke
Bryan Florida Georgia Line all the Bro
country stuff now those same people are
sharing this video and they're calling
This Outlaw country and I'm like hold on
a minute just a few weeks ago you would
have never called the student Outlaw
country you would have never said that
about him he was he was you know the Bro
country establishment so to speak but
you know the country artists that
inspired me the most like Willie
Nelson's a big one and Johnny Cash and
they were they were very open-minded
people and they had a lot of progressive
viewpoints um you know there was uh the
song I always point to the song The Man
in Black by Johnny Cash where he talked
about why he wore the black and he said
I wore it for the poor and the beaten
down and for the people living on the
you know rough side of town uh you know
that that's what that was originally
about and it was it was people like
Johnny Cash grew up in a small town in
Arkansas uh they they grew up in those
small towns they lived that life and
then their life you know reflected over
into their art but nowadays it feels
like that the that the art just reflects
the lifestyle it's like it's like the
People starts over here they got the
imagery you know they got the cowboy hat
they got the boots jeans all that they
got the imagery of it but a lot of the
times they don't really have the the
foundation underneath them and I think
that's uh like that's always been like I
said that's always been the argument
against the music that Jason Aldean and
different people put out and to see
people calling him an outlaw today is
pretty hypocritical considering two
weeks ago they were dead against him and
they would have never caught him an
outlawed a million years right well to
some degree a lot of country music fans
who like
um Old Country see new country as pop
music they don't even really see a lot
of now uh Chris Stapleton does a lot of
good he does a lot of good country music
again another person Chris Stapleton who
is not a bigot who is not it was not
about lashing down at people you know
and punching down and being racist in
his songs overtly racist in his songs
and I I like that you called it bro
country I like that I I like that
because you know that's one thing that I
think uh about the Jason Aldean song
they wrote the lyrics for a certain
person they produced the music video for
a certain person and the outrage
afterwards the whining about oh I'm
being canceled was for a certain person
it's all old white country geek boys who
had trucks to compensate for their
little penises with their big Trump
flags on the back they're bro country
they're not even real Jason Aldean isn't
even from a Small Town Tennessee Brando
he's from a town of like 200 000 and he
lives in Nashville now if I and I'm
right on that I believe he lives in
Nashville which is Nashville I don't
think Nashville is considered a small
town either
um so to call Jason Aldean country is a
derelict and anyone's duty but I I keep
I keep seeing these um again these
comments about how everyone's like oh
country music has always been this or
always been that and I want to go back
to her just a recent story about a
country music artist who basically told
the eat boys the Bro country boys to go
[__] themselves uh when all this the Kid
Rock the epitome the epitome of bro
country I mean this guy was a rapper in
the 90s and then he'd act like he was a
punk rocker and now he's somehow a
country music artist I don't understand
man but anyways the point is this is
that when Kid Rock uh shot shot up his
three or four cases of Bud Light and
everyone lost their minds because Dylan
Mulvaney did a marketing
um one video on Instagram and it's
really because they're scared that
they'd want to [__] her that's why
they're that's why that's what it is
that's that's what it is Brando that's
what it is they're just scared they'd
want to [__] her but here's the thing
here's the thing is that
is that Garth Brooks
um was not going to not serve Bud Light
and his bar during CMA Fest and for all
those out there who don't know in
Nashville CMA Fest is like one of the
biggest events of the year there's
hundreds of thousands of people that go
to Nashville to celebrate CMA Fest they
have tons of live music it's it's
concerts everywhere the bars are full
and people were mad that Garth Brooks
was going to serve Bud Light in his bar
and Garth Brooks basically told them
well if you feel that hateful because of
a brand like that then you don't [__]
you don't come in my bar I don't give a
[__] if you're that big of an [__] so
we have these little these little
um these recent stories even like Garth
Brooks because it's really weird I mean
you can speak to this I remember a time
when Garth Brooks in the early 90s was
given pushback from the country music
crowd because he was for the he was in
an ally of the gay community
that's a big one do you think do you
think people like Garth Brooks and Dolly
Parton and Willie Nelson are going to
stand up for Jason Dean here no not at
all I don't think so at all and you know
it's it's uh I'm glad you brought that
up because uh especially I want to talk
about something when you mentioned Kid
Rock and you know that's kind of what
started the whole Bud Light thing is but
he came out and shot up those cases of
Bud Light that got everybody you know
ramped up and ready to go uh but the
thing that's always bugged me really
about Kid Rock and I ain't gonna lie to
you you know that first album we put out
Devil Without a Cause I had it on CD
sure I did too a lot of people did
um but where he lost me was when you
know he's from Detroit you know and he
comes down south and he starts waving a
rebel flag around and capitalizing on
all the things that you know all the
things that I've worked hard to get away
from you know as a southerner I've grown
up here and there's a whole lot of
things I've had to learn that wasn't
right there's a lot of things I was
taught growing up that I realized hey
that wasn't necessarily true there's a
lot of uncomfortable truths about racism
that I had to confront and face and
someone like Kid Rock to me came down
and he capitalized on all that all the
all the worst of it that people like us
here in the South that you know had to
grow up and get out from under and you
know when I start these campaigns to
boycott businesses you know uh there's a
whole lot of working people that works
for those businesses and they don't
realize the long-term effect that can
have on a lot of people
but I know I never was I I had Garth
Brooks's first couple albums too and
then as time went on and he got a little
bit more poppy it kind of you know got
away from me and I didn't really listen
to it anymore but when we're sitting
here today and I've actually got a song
I haven't uh released it yet but I did
write a song talking about having a beer
with Garth because I never thought that
we would be over here where now we're
having beer with Garth and because like
you know um like I said I had those
first couple albums he lost me during
the whole pop years that he did but uh
here we are now when he's basically
saying hey if you guys you know are
going to be an [__] just don't come
to my bar and there's people bashing him
for that right I'm like what a crazy
world we live in that a man says hey if
you if you have a problem with me
serving a certain beer and I'm going to
be all inclusive and I'm going to
welcome everybody and if you don't
believe everybody's gonna be welcome
here then go somewhere else and people's
making him the bad guy right and that
that was really um I don't know that
really got me to thinking how crazy the
worlds became it's it's a while it's a
wild time to be alive I'm not gonna I'm
not I'm not gonna lie and and really uh
it's it's something else uh when uh the
roots of country music really are
artists like Willie Nelson uh uh Woody
Guthrie and and for people who don't
know who Woody Guthrie is his guitar he
carried around a guitar and it literally
had written on it this machine kills
fascism yeah because Woody Guthrie would
speak
um to the the poor and the downtrodden
and he would he would speak against
corporations
um and it's it's crazy it's crazy that
the time that we live in
um where Jason Aldean is on stage crying
about being canceled because he he
intentionally did something racist and
you know the other thing I want to bring
up
because a lot of people have said oh
well you're actually you know you're
participating in Kansas culture when you
cancel Jason Aldean and I'm like well
CMT just made a decision about this one
video right yeah I remember years ago
and it was 20 over 20 years ago uh when
at the time the chicks they were known
as the ditchy chicks then yeah they're
the chicks now
um they came out on stage and they spoke
against George W bush they basically
said [__] him you know he's not our
president kind of thing yeah and not
only did they they did they hate on the
chick's word they blacklisted them on
the [__] radio like they would not
play any of their songs it's not like
the chicks released a song that was
against George W bush they were singing
on stage and they told their fans [__]
him and they cheered their fans cheered
yeah I think what she said too you know
she said we're we're ashamed our
presence from Texas you know right
foreign
and like you said they they uh
completely banned them all the way
across the board it wasn't just one
video right and it's and you know it's
crazy because it's the same exact people
who cheered that on and who would still
cheer that on today who are crying about
Jason Aldean not being on CMT yeah say
[__] and that only tells you
that this isn't about cancer culture
this is a this is about having
permission to be the worst version of
yourself right that's what this is about
that's what trumpism really at the heart
of American fascism this trumpism
movement that has taken hold of 10 or 12
percent of the country that's really at
the heart of it that's what it's about
is he gives me he gives me whether it's
Jason Aldean or Trump or Jason Aldean
and Trump shoes here because that's
basically what it is is Jason Aldean
singing about trumpism
uh it's about them giving them
permission to be the worst version of
themselves which isn't exactly country
music I don't think I don't either and
you know you're right Trump did Empower
that and he gave people the courage to
go inside the quiet Parts out loud you
know they went ahead and they went ahead
and went for it and you know like I said
before I just think that a lot of the
country music that really inspired me
and one of the reason I want to be a
musician was the was the stuff that
spoke for the people and what they were
actually going through and and um you
know there's there's good and bad in all
music and there's been uh there has been
racist country songs there's that has
happened but uh the genre as a whole
that's not what it was founded on at all
and uh and I think that uh you know it
was originally meant to be the music of
people living in small towns no pun
intended but it was meant to be for for
Royal country people and and what they
go through and the things they battle
but I think over time man honestly I
feel like that over time you know
um they didn't want to focus on that
because if if they focused on that
mainstream country music that would be a
reflection of the Republican politics
that ain't working so they have to
create this phony narrative right that
that everything's just you know
hunky-dory in the small towns and and
then they can it's all about culture
wars and it's all about distracting from
what's really going on in this part of
the world I I think you're absolutely
right I'm gonna play
um Hunters Hunter has uh hard-ons for
Hunter is it called hard-ons for Hunter
yeah hard on for Hunter hard on for
Hunter but I want to play you a video
real quick uh of a one of the best
takedowns that I've seen so far
um of Jason Aldean and this song in
particular
um now there's a lot of speculation a
lot of people pulling out oh well uh
this is obviously what makes it racist
and this is what makes it racist I mean
there's so many things that make it
racist but this is one of the best
takedowns and I want to get your opinion
of this takedown of Jason Aldean here it
is okay peace Jason Aldean ran that's
him right there Jason Aldean running
when the worst mass shooting in the
history of this country was playing out
at Jason Aldean's concert before his
very eyes Jason Aldean duct and ran for
safety as his adoring fans or being
mowed down by a gun Jason Aldean ran
Jason Aldean didn't go get his
Granddaddy's Gun track down the shooter
to go all Walker Texas right Ranger on
him no Jason Aldean ran and when the
time came for Jason Aldean to do his
tough guy chest thumping so much right
in a small town somehow mass shootings
didn't make the cut of his video too
busy glad handing the police and
protecting a piece of fabric these
colors don't run well Jason Aldean you
do now to be clear Jason Aldean I'm not
calling you a coward for running that
was in fact the safest option for you so
relax with all the tough guy talk about
what you're going to do if we try that
in a small town we already know what
you're gonna do Jason Aldean
we out here
and that's really the story here is
Jason Aldean is a poser I mean you know
that's one of the things that really
leaped off the page about his video to
me when I seen it and I didn't hear the
song separately I I watched the video
and heard the song first at the same
time and that's one of the things that
really just jumped out at me immediately
was hey this guy survived a mass
shooting uh you'd think you would have a
different take on it and wouldn't write
a song that to me sounds like he's
encouraging people to violence it's uh I
just thought that was uh extremely odd
that he would do that and I like that
guys in the video I don't blame him in
that scenario for running uh because he
does he can't protect himself at that
point he is a setting duck if he stands
there so I I I'm not giving him hell for
running either but he uh he tries to
take now on this tough guy act and uh
and and I you just think that someone I
I don't know what I would do if I was in
scenario I don't want to put myself in
those shoes but I'm just saying it seems
like someone in that scenario that
survived something like that would have
a more would have a different approach
rather than try to to try to decide
violence and also something too is I
felt like that this whole thing was a
little bit it was like you know okay it
felt like he was going back to 2020 and
talking about that it was like we're
we're we're past that now we're over
here and why are you trying to still
pick at that when are you ever going to
let that go and there's another crater
on a tick tock Named Destiny Stark I
don't know if you saw her videos but she
actually breaks down the footage that he
used and uh it actually wasn't
um it wasn't real footage from here in
America a lot of it there was part of it
was from a German uh music festival uh
where the part where the girl's slipping
off the police you know that was
actually uh took from a German festival
there was other things took from Ukraine
so but that but you can tell that the
people that did this video they they
tailored it
to fit that narrative for the Bro
country the Bro Country Boys yeah
because they didn't use nothing for
January 6th right you know they didn't
use anything from that where where they
were actually stomping on flags and
using Flags to beat the cops yes yeah
exactly you know and uh and those are
the people that are like yeah we love
Jason Aldean like what wait wait a
second wait a second you're the ones who
went to the Capitol and and used the
flag to to hit cops
with their narrative you know that's
right that wouldn't fit the narrative
they was doing for that if Jason Aldean
had said let's say you made the same
video said the same thing but he'd have
used that for his backdrop the right
would be canceling it Kid Rock will be
going out and burning those albums right
so that that's you know there's so many
people and it's funny too because people
like us will get called the racist when
we point out the racism they'll try to
Gaslight and say I had this one Creator
uh on Tick Tock making a video he
featured me in it and it was a it was a
black content creator named Oscar Tatum
and he was like you know he's like look
he's like white Liberals are outraged
with this video and then he showed a
clip where I was talking about it being
racist and he basically said that I was
being a racist because I noticed it you
know and I'm like I'm like so so I
noticed the racism but now I'm the
racist right right right and he goes on
to have he goes on to have uh like white
people who are who are supportive of the
song but he didn't show one that's not
you know because he's trying to create
his own narrative and so uh it's just a
lot of gaslighting man like and like you
said there's a whole lot of uh Trump
empowered this and at the end of the day
I I really I don't think this song would
even exist without Donald Trump you know
I think I think you're exactly right
you're exactly come along and empowered
that redneckery oh that's just the word
I made up but had he not come on he had
empowered that I don't think people
would be saying those type of songs you
know well I hope you keep singing your
songs and this is this is one of my
favorite right here it's um I appreciate
it hard ons hard on hard on for Hunter
let's listen
marjorie's got a hard-on for Hunter
talks about him all the time
shows off his dick pics of Congress
they drive her out of her mind
[Music]
she tries to suppress it
cries like hell to project
[Music]
she's got a heart on for Hunter
at least that's what we suspect
[Music]
Junior's got a heart on for Hunter
he always hands me on the plane
for all of his dirty feelings
and the time he missed waste is cocaine
he thinks that we all can't sing
[Music]
don't think we have to ask why
with all the world's problems getting
back on our feet
breaking our backs just to make ends
meet they just can't help it they just
can't stop
in the sea Hunter's laptop
they all got a heart on for Hunter
he's there to fight and distract
the truth won't get in the way of their
stories
they won't
[Music]
party
like he did back in his days
but they all got a hard-on for Hunter
and the truth is they just couldn't hang
one of the best love songs in the last
couple weeks to be quite honest they
love his yeah now you said without Trump
we wouldn't have the Jason Aldean song
but I guarantee you without Trump we
wouldn't have the hard-ons for hunter or
something either
that's true you're absolutely right I
got it I gotta admit to that right so
you gotta You Gotta Give Trump his dude
there he kind of he kind of set it up
for you to write each yeah he kind of
birthed this whole thing I'm doing
really at the end of the day right uh
you know the one the one line there at
the end of the song that I had to throw
in it's funny to me how these people
they'd love to demonized Hunter for his
drug use you know they love the demonize
that part of him they're the same people
that go to a Hank Williams Jr concert
and brag about oh I wouldn't say Hank Jr
and he was wasted man
yeah and I'm like if he was anybody else
you would want to party with him right
right exactly these people that they
don't make no sense it's like wiping
before you poop it just doesn't make any
sense at all listen Tennessee Brando I
know these songs are available somewhere
on online uh for people to download so
tell us where they can get access to
these songs as you record them and you
put them out where can where can people
go and I know I know the mods have your
link tree I think that's right tell the
audience well definitely follow the link
tree because a lot of times like these
songs I've not actually recorded them
with my group yet video version out so
they are on YouTube if you click the
link tree you can find it on YouTube
Twitter Facebook threads Instagram all
those places but when I get them
recorded and out to the world they're on
Spotify and iTunes and pretty much all
the streaming services so I included
those in my link tree too and uh you
guys can find them there I've got I've
got two different uh profiles on Spotify
the Tennessee brand knows the more
current political stuff and then the
Brandon Folsom stuff is the stuff I was
writing before all this happened so uh
people can get on there and check that
out and the link tree will take them
pretty much where they need to go well
thank you for joining us and everybody
the link is down in the description
below the minds are putting in the chat
as well go go go visit Tennessee
Randall's linktree and with your
permission my friend I'm gonna keep
playing these uh country music
Tony I appreciate you so much and thank
you so much for having me on the show oh
well come back anytime you need me
that's that sounds great my friend that
sounds great Tennessee mirando everyone
go check out the songs that he's got
recorded and check out his social media
as he does more of these songs he speed
writes these songs that kill fascism
um that's that's the that's the key here
Tennessee Randall thanks for joining us
my friend everyone stick around stick
around we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
Tennessee Brando everybody
go get his music
[Music]
can you believe that how fast he he
pumps these out I didn't know about the
uh the experience that he has with speed
riding songs it makes sense now though
doesn't it makes sense how he can
really pop these songs out I think it's
a great talent and it's a it's a voice
that is needed in the space that we're
in today especially when we have um
people like Ben Shapiro and paying for
Barbie tickets and then paying for
Barbies
so that he can burn them in a barrel I'm
not kidding you we're gonna talk about
that we're going to talk about that
today we're also going to talk about
when these indictments are coming down
what the suspicion is
um I'm trying to keep on on the news so
that we um
hillbilly that we have the the news
ready uh if it pops off but I suspect
that it will take longer
then just a few days to get Donald Trump
indicted and the reason why I believe
that is because of the history that we
have with Jack Smith in the last date
now this one is completely different the
crime is older to be quite Fair
um again January 6 happened before
Donald Trump obstructed and stole our
documents
um so there's that but but again again
you know expect expect
um Donald Trump to be indicted within a
few weeks on the January 6 case uh but
really the the thing that I want to see
is who is going to be his
co-conspirators on this January 6th
indictment are we going to see Rudy
Giuliani on a Federal indictment are we
going to see Jeffrey Clark
um are are we going to see John Eastman
is Mark Meadows gonna work his way on
this indictment with with only one or
two charges that makes it obvious that
Mark Meadow has flipped maybe Rudy
Giuliani has flipped and he gets a
lighter charger no charges
um on this indictment so that's that's a
really
it's really what I'm looking for but you
know there was uh and I wonder if we can
pull the clip here there was an
interview that Trump did on a rate an
Iowa radio show
and he's basically saying that if they
indict him it's going to be dangerous
which is all [__]
this [__] idea that his supporters
Are Gonna Save him is so stupid
what they already did that want the most
of them that are willing to go commit
violence for him in Mass have already
been arrested charged been to prison for
January 6th they didn't show up in New
York they didn't show up in Florida it's
all a bunch of [__] hot air
these people are a bunch of fake ass
tough guys just like Jason Aldean
they're [__] posers they're not
really tough guys because if you gotta
call yourself a tough guy or try to act
tough
bite saying I'm tough yeah it's going to
be dangerous if you indict me my my
tough guy guys are gonna come get you
get the [__] out of here
that nonsense
there's no way no way that you can
convince me
that that Trump or Jason Aldean or
anyone that supports them some kind of
[__] tough guy [__] that [__] that
ain't what that ain't what real men do
speaking of real men
I wouldn't seen the Barbie movie this
weekend over the weekend I went with my
daughter and some of her friends and
some of them I was the only I was the
only man that went with him but I had to
go see this movie because uh Gabe
Sanchez told me that I would understand
why Republicans were gonna freak out and
hate this movie
and from the first couple minutes and it
didn't disappoint that that was for sure
in that in that realm I knew watching it
like oh my God they're going to be so
triggered by this they're so predictably
unpredictable aren't they like Ben
Shapiro Jesus Christ and get a new
[__] act good Lord you're mad at a
Barbie and they're really mad because oh
Ken Ken is uh Ken Ken is secondary yeah
Ken is secondary there wouldn't be
without Barbie there wouldn't be can you
dumb [__] how the hell don't
they know this stuff
Jesus [__] Christ they whitewash
everything I mean everything
even the history of bar the movie is
about a doll bin it's about a [__]
doll
and the doll empowered women and really
honestly in part of the film if you want
to know the honest truth they try they
tried to to give a reason why Barbie
wasn't so good for women and and part of
her history
they try to they try to establish that
in the movie
and I think I think the movie is a good
movie
it's cheesy
it's kind of corny kinda
but if you but if you love Barbie and
you play with Barbies and you love that
brand you're gonna love this movie
there's no question about that you're
gonna love this movie unless you have a
really small penis and you're super
insecure about it then you're gonna hate
this movie especially if you can't make
a woman come you're really gonna hate
this movie because that's truly why
they're mad games inches they're mad
they're mad because they they just can't
please a woman so that's what they hate
about Barbie really honestly yeah yeah
yeah I mean it's you know they
I'm working on a what was that right now
and I
I bring up
and I talked about this yesterday in in
the weekend Roundup that I do on my
patreon and we kind of broke it down uh
this absurdity by the right with
everything they do right it's always
like oh this is so woke or this is
propaganda or this is communist or this
is anti-man this is feminist this is
whatever it might be right
um but a lot of it is because they're
you know insecure about their own
manhood
um their own place in society because
God forbid a woman has you know a role
equal if not greater than them and they
make as much in in salary if not greater
than them or they have a more uh
important role in the household
uh these things on top of their you know
so their misogyny on top of their racism
they're just overall xenophobia
these are things
that the right are very scared about and
these are things that the movie
talks about right right it talks about
this unfair image that Barbie has on
society it talks about you know Barbie
being independent as as just a thing
right but then you've got people like
ginger Gates who's like oh there's like
definitely Low T in the movie uh as in
testosterone what do you saying what do
you say what do you say listen I watched
the movie okay Ryan Gosling is anything
but low T in the movie dude is super
yoked the guy the guy looks like he
hadn't drank a glass of water in like
three weeks he's so dehydrated probably
has guaranteed anything but rice cakes
well the guys the guy's 42. okay and as
we know biologically our body lowers
testosterone over time sure and Men it's
a thing that happens for uh for you know
testosterone you know replacement
treatment for low T levels will get T
injections just for maintenance just to
be like hey cognitive function
metabolism your hormones your hormones
everything going on so that's it's not
unusual for men as they get older to get
like a maintenance shot every year or
whatever it might be
for Ryan Gosling and I and I brought up
a photo I was like look here he is in
Crazy Stupid Love natural great bod
awesome would definitely would
definitely go gay for Ryan Gosling
ER if I was gay Hall Pass I mean Ryan
Reynolds for sure okay
um all right who else
this is really going to piss off the
right winger I mean dude let me tell you
these are beautiful men who not only not
only are you know handsome beautiful
whatever they also respect women right
okay so
look that's that's got a deep place in
my heart as well now
Ryan Gosling you look at Crazy Stupid
Love and you're like oh man right
there's the scene where they redo the uh
Dirty Dancing moment right with Emma
Stone
in that movie you're like oh damn okay
got abs he's ripped yeah you rip and
it's it's natural natural body you know
worked out in this movie if you look at
the composition of his body as well as
the formation of his pecs I'm like holy
[__]
no he had to be Ken no I know exactly
exactly
but what I'm saying is like when she
says Low T I'm like this dude is Auntie
from this role like they're 100 was on
gear 100 was on gear and you know there
there won't say it right Ryan got and
there's nothing wrong with that a lot of
actors do that to prepare for a role
because they don't want to they don't
want to have to [__] use computer
generation to wash them right they
rather them look the part and just and
just be the part and so they do train
like uh uh uh
Jesus Christ Chris Hemsworth with Thor
it's obvious these days a year
um uh uh Henry right the rock they they
take gear no I know Henry Cavill well
actually didn't he's the one person
there's no way there's no way that it's
not even because he did it this
afternoon he did it no no no he did the
same way because Christopher Reeves was
like I don't want to take anything I
want it to be natural right because
Christopher Ruiz is kind of really
scrawny before he took yeah and then
Henry uh Henry Cavill was the same way
he's like I don't want to take anything
I'm going to push myself which is very
impressive when you look back and when
he was a kid like over time he used to
be like a little pudgy little British
kid and over time he got more and more
in shape why why pudgy is pudgy British
well I'm just wondering because I didn't
know if pudgy is British and chubby as
America it just sounds like pudgy right
but he sounds British doesn't it yeah
yeah I see someone here who said Kevin
says whoever said Gabe is funny as [__]
dude I've been hearing Gabe since I was
in the first or second grade so you all
are late to the table right link to the
party uh but no I mean those are I mean
dude Ryan Gosling look [__]
pristine in that movie so did everyone
else and that's the thing too and now oh
Margot Robbie is [__] stupid and it's
so funny that they're like oh hey Barbie
I wouldn't [__] her like come on man
it's Margot what are you talking about
even even a gay dude might go straight
for her that's how beautiful she is and
even in one part of the movie and I
don't want to give it away but one part
of the movie they even break the third
wall for that they make the fourth wall
go for otherwise excuse me they break
the fourth wall for that right which is
a great part but I'm not gonna say what
happens yeah yeah gives it a run that
part for you but it is great when they
break yeah so you saw it so you know
exactly why well yeah I saw it I told
you I was gonna lose I know I know I got
a great story about it too I got a girl
okay well yeah and and so on top of
those things it's also the fact that
no longer because the thing that Ginger
uh Ginger Gates said uh Matt Gates his
wife they went to the Barbie Premiere
they dressed up don't go to the movie if
anything get an inspiration the Margot
Robbie was great yes the set design was
great yes this was great yes I agree
with you there and then you're like uh
Low T
um there's no faith faith or family
which is interesting because what the
[__] there's no reason and also in the
history of Barbie never has Barbie been
like hey man it's your Barbie there's
never been preacher Barbie or none
Barbie well also you've you've never had
you've never had Barbie with an
accessory that was like okay here's a
Pew and you can pray now like these
aren't things that come with it there
was never any mention of of family
because she doesn't have a family okay
she doesn't have reproductive organs
okay and when they did try to do that
[__] they had people like Midge which
they discontinued they had [__]
Skipper which was grow up Barbie which
is you wind her arm and she extends a
few inches and her boobs come out it's
[__] weird they actually they
actually addressed some of this in the
movie right which of which they couldn't
address every single Barbie in the movie
because there's so many of them but they
do go through some of these and it's
great but I've got I got some uh
breaking news here I've got a picture a
new uh photo this photo evidence that
Ben Shapiro did did go dry address up as
Ken for the Barbie movie here is Ben
Shapiro apparently pantsless
um I mean it makes sense right like we
know that his wife or he can't get his
wife uh wet you know maybe he's
anatomically incorrect like did you see
my photo uh yes I did I'm gonna show
that one all right I'm gonna show that
one I'm gonna show I'm gonna show you
playing Ben Shapiro playing Ryan Gosling
dressed up as as
it's great it's great but here's the
story that I have about um about the
Barbie so we went and seen it and um in
the movie not to give too much of the
plot away but it IT addresses the
patriarchy right uh in the real world
because in Barbie land it's Barbie land
obviously right the women rule of course
that's the whole idea about Barbie land
this fantasy I don't know Ben knows this
or not but Barbie land is not real it's
just a it's an imaginary idea like it's
just an idea someone's head that they've
kind of put in a movie I don't even know
is that or not you know maybe he thinks
it's real but in the real world the
patriarchy runs things in Barbie land
Barbies run things because it's Barbie
land so and they addressed the
patriarchy and how Ken gets kind of
jealous that he didn't have it kind of
thing and as the movie's going uh are
ending we're watching the credits
because now Marvel has ruined going to
the movies and you have to stay for the
entire [__] credits
um just in case there's some Easter egg
or in credit scene I mean that's right I
didn't stay there was none ah [__] I
just run it for everyone but no don't
have to stay you don't have to stay for
the credits you should look at all the
people and uh observe how many people
[__] worked on this film that is
important with the strike going on right
now how many people actually worked on
this film to make it happen
um but the thing is this
is that this dude who had two little
girls I'm assuming they were his
daughters or granddaughters I I don't
know
he walked I was in the aisle seat and
then we were probably eight rows back
from the front right and we had we had
four we had like 10 people with all the
little my daughter and her friends that
came with her and and we made it a big
kind of event and this guy's walking out
of theater with two little girls
and he leans over to me and he kind of
TAPS me on his shoulder and he's like
the patriarchy am I right I'm like what
did you just watch the movie I I I I
wasn't sure if I was the only dude that
he saw as he was exiting so he thought
he would get a bro moment in or
something I wasn't really sure I didn't
know exactly what he meant I didn't know
if he was joking if he was serious if he
was looking for validation for himself
now that he just was
masculated by this movie I don't know
what the hell his thoughts were yeah but
he he took the time to stop and tell me
the patriarchy am I right
you know what I'm talking about bro uh
someone said Captain terp says a broment
I guess he wanted a Broman I guess
oh my God that's so funny that somebody
would stop and and be like just do a
complete stranger right I didn't know
who this guy was he didn't know I mean
I'm assuming he didn't know who the hell
I was
um I don't know how you would know in a
dark theater like that but never know
and you never know but I haven't been
approached in public and people know who
I am but it's just crazy that that he
would take his time to stop with his two
I guess daughters granddaughter what
what whatever I don't know who they were
he's like two little girls with him
um that's the one thing that Ben Shapiro
said about this he's really upset that
there was a bunch of women and girls in
the Barbie movie he's like I was the
only dude there like well I mean I'm not
saying I also want to point out the fact
that he was like my producers forced me
to go of course yeah did he have
daughters doesn't he have daughters yeah
and he just had a kid I think he just
had a son did he take the kids to the
theater is that no no not that I know of
I mean there was definitely someone
there who took the photo of him so there
was at least one person with him I mean
I've done the math and he spent over
uh if you buy if you go with a child
ticket it's 9.75 so two children's
tickets for him and who he went with or
maybe an adult you know anyway it's like
20 bucks uh 20 bucks plus almost 100
bucks and he was like
around 120 bucks a little bit less than
that but I think it might be more
there was a couple of expenses because I
did the math on I looked up the the toys
that he lit on fire and I did the math
because no one else did everyone's like
oh he lit these things up I was like
look he may or may not have owned these
toys before some of these are exclusive
to the movie but I've done the math I've
gone to Mattel I've looked up the prices
and there were only three locations that
those toys are sold
I saw that and I saw in your Tweet there
was someone commented because I showed
it yesterday on the um
on the patreon thing okay and um your
math there but the thing was is that
someone said oh well it's a business
expense I'm like yeah but Mattel still
gets their money yeah
people don't understand they're like
what the [__] I saw people in my
comments that were like oh yeah and he
probably made a ton of money off the
video that may be very well true right
but here's the thing when you're
boycotting a company
you're buying M M's and you're smashing
them on the ground you're buying Bud
Light and you're shooting it with an
AR-15 you're buying these things just to
destroy them once the company gets the
money
a sales a sale they're not like you know
what someone purchased six Bud Light
cases at Walmart to shoot them up
um there's six of them that's not how
they determine it they just see it as
sales they [__] they just see it as
sales yeah doing great we we sold a
truck a Barbie doll a Barbie doll and a
Ken doll doesn't matter boom boom and
sold some tickets at the theater right
is that that's the other story is
Oppenheimer I haven't seen it yet
oppenheimer's supposed to be a great
movie
um yeah supposed to be great have you
seen it I haven't seen it yet I I had a
friend who went to the IMAX theater
um at the Chinese Theater here where
it's playing LA because that's the only
one that has a 70 millimeter Max
experience and he was like it was
amazing he had a couple issues because
he was like oh there's no like there's
no Jewish people playing actual there's
like no Jewish actors playing Jewish
people in the movie they were a couple
people that
um that weren't mentioned he was like my
he's like my grandmother was actually
one of the people who worked on that
project no [__] and there wasn't really
any mention of that group so there's a
couple of things I got but more he's
like but the story is phenomenal the
music is great the there's no action in
it but it is like a three-hour movie
that goes by very quickly he said right
well that's great so it makes it a great
idea it did have a one of my friends who
went to go see Barbie he said he was
next to in the next to the theater the
IMAX theater for Oppenheimer and there's
been this running joke this whole this
uh Barbie right and so this idea that
there was a you're going to be next to
the theater and you're gonna hear these
like explosions and crazy intense like
audio going next like oh this is a happy
little fun like Barbie movie right
and there was a there was a meme that
was sent around which is like the scene
from the original Spider-Man with Toby
McGuire where the Green Goblin blasts
through ant May's wall praying she's
like dude it's like just like blast
through
he was like legit the movie was our the
move when we started our movie we were
halfway through and that movie was going
on and it was next door and he was like
no joke it was just like that Meme he's
like the amount of uh like sound
reverberating off the walls of that
theater into our theater as like a like
a complete dichotomy of like oh this is
this is a fun movie and this is a
[__] right very crazy movie dramatic
well um the thing is is that Barbie has
made way more move way more money than
Oppenheimer so far yeah well that was
also that was also predicted now the
amount of money that they made is is
more well in both of their categories
and I want to say that for uh the right
Wingers out there that are getting
really pissed off about Barbie you're
only helping it like you're only helping
it like you're only like you're only
giving people a reason I wasn't gonna go
see it in theaters until you were like
yeah this is really going to piss
Republicans oh no I gotta go see this
[__] I have to see this because
they're gonna freak out about it so I'm
glad I watched it over the weekend while
you're looking at the numbers up there I
want to show you this is this is Ryan
Gosling as Ken this is him in the movie
there's a a part where he's dancing
around and you can see he's got a black
shirt which you know I like black I like
black I'm not gonna lie I like black
t-shirts you guys know I wear black a
lot
um he's got a black T-shirt black uh
slacks on here and a black belt now Ben
Shapiro showed up uh in in the theater
and this is the actual picture the one I
showed her earlier was was a spoof but
here's him dressed as Ken like literally
he's wearing the [__] costume that
Ryan Gosling or an imitation of the
constant Ryan Gosling that was wearing
in the movie uh which is [__]
hilarious right and he's posing in front
of the the sign like ow the craziest
part is this dork has a [__] notebook
what kind of creepo it's not even a
notebook it's a it's a a legal pad right
based on a daily wire like it's got
daily wire Masthead on um because he
uses that during his movie review oh the
video that he released and I didn't
watch anything but the Clippers burning
the Barbies I've done a fair amount of
research I know that he was at a
cinemark as you look in the back there's
only one Cinemark in Boca Raton where he
lives this is that Boca Raton wait wait
a second I I thought he wasn't an
elitist no no
[Music]
is that just like a middle class area
like a whole word are you sure are you
sure upper upper are you sure come on
he's he's I'm just saying he's a man
he's the man of the people man he's a
man no man of the people in a gated
community
and he wants to make sure to keep don't
come near me I'm gonna send my my
security on you right I'm sure I'm sure
he loves the uh uh Small Town song by
Jason Aldean when he does try that in a
small wealthy town right try that in a
small gated wealthy community where we
won't let anyone in that's why I live in
a gated community because I'm scared of
the world so I'm scared of the pores I'm
scared of the pores okay that's why we
have Ventures around us they're after me
those pores
so so I I looked this up it was the um
you know the Cinemark in Boca Raton that
he went to right the I'm assuming
because he also said that he went to go
see Oppenheimer I believe was what he
said at the beginning of the of this
little video which means that if he went
on the same day he probably went to a
matinee showing of Barbie you know I
think he went to Barbie first I have to
assume that like you know
foreign
Ben Shapiro wakes up right he wakes up
at 6 30 he gets a large glass of
Metamucil you know he he starts his day
and he goes he goes for an evening
stroll in his his little walker shoes
right and then he's like okay the the
joints are loose the joints I don't know
I think I think he drives his Range
Rover to a Starbucks and buys the most
expensive no I think he's got a golf
cart and he drives that golf cart yeah
of course everyone in Florida has a golf
cart and I think that you know he gets
his you know a nice warm glass of
Metamucil in the morning you know stirs
it rich in fiber because that's isn't
that the new uh State State uh flower is
the Metamucil yeah it is okay it's
amazing and so then he he got in he got
into his golf cart and he he and he
drove a couple blocks away to the
Cinemark Theater
which is like it's
yeah anyway went to the Cinemark Theater
bought a ticket assuming he went to the
same movie and or like uh did a double
feature went to both movies he probably
started in the morning I want to say
like maybe the the 10 a.m showing okay
what 10 a.m showing Barbie he's like let
me watch it get it out of my mind and
then I can watch his movie about utter
destruction you know what you know
what's funny I bet he was seething still
about Barbie and how much it offended
his manhood while he's sitting in
Oppenheimer he probably had to go watch
Oppenheimer twice because he wasted God
damn it I hate Barbie she makes me feel
like an end well I mean really honestly
do you think Margot Robbie
um would give any two [__] about Ben
Shapiro no no you know what she's doing
what she's laughing her way all the way
to the bank right now I how many points
do you think she got
because not only that I hope she
negotiated a deal to where she gets part
of the toys because they're making you
know yeah
exactly and those Ken and Barbie movie
toys are the ones that that Shapiro
decided to that's hilarious burn in a
trash can so we basically gave Margot
Robbie and oh that was the other thing
it was those are the other costs it was
the it was the three three dolls plus
the truck plus the matches plus the
lighter fluid because that's what he
actually needed to light it on fire and
then the movie tickets so all in all
he's like over 120 130 bucks just for
this bit and for people like oh it's a
move it's a it's a business expense
that's fine but he still got their money
still got the money doesn't matter well
here's here's that you dressed as Ben
Shapiro dressed as
Candace Ryan Gosling dressed or is I
don't know it's confusing yeah and here
you are you actually got in the Box I
got in the Box dude got in the in the
what's in the box what's in the box tell
me what's in the box man so I got in the
Box I got in the Box as a bit just for
this whoa whoa are you saying you spent
all this money just for this bit oh my
god oh no I just happened to be where
the movie was again oh I see I get you
so I made sure you just made sure to
dress up yeah because I was going I was
going to the mall and that we were doing
a couple errands and I was like oh I
should wear this because I remember they
have the box for people to take photos
in
I was like I gotta do it I gotta do it
because I'm I have I'm writing this what
was that and I was like
I can't not it was also
it was insanely unfortunate the timing
because it's been so [__] hot it was
like 90 like dry heat nine but it was
like heavy it was like 95 I want to say
when we were there and it's an outdoor
mall and luckily this is indoor where
the theater is so I could walk in and
get some AC but holy [__] man it was
like so hot and I was wearing I was
wearing black shoes because I forgot
uh I forgot how much of this you could
actually see so I gotta wear the black
shoes so I put on my PF Flyers I got my
black jeans my black belt and my black
shirt and I've already got dark hair so
I was like [__] a tree I had the
whole pet you didn't have the legal bed
though I was gonna bring I was gonna
bring paper but then I was like uh this
is my this is why Gabe Sanchez freaks
out about details because I'm gonna
bring this up that he doesn't have a
legal pad it's gonna bother him like
well you know I I thought about it and I
was like well technically Ben's doing
his version of Ryan and I'm doing my
version of Ben so oh okay yeah
I also think it's a better version in
the sense that like I got in the box
right he was in front of the sign right
whatever Ryan's in the movie get in the
box so yeah Sanchez says here here's
what you say me dressed as Ben Shapiro
dressed as Ryan Gosling dressed as Skin
um and it gives you a three-part story
here yeah of the insanity of where
they're losing their minds about an
imaginary movie it's not yeah it's say
it's not based on anything but the
imagination so yesterday I was talking
with the people that were in my uh the
the patreon weekend Roundup and I said
right now the projection is 155 in the
U.S
I wouldn't and globally it's 337 and I
was like I wouldn't be surprised if we
see something that's much that's
actually greater than 155 when the when
the numbers come out this morning uh for
the weekend yeah I wouldn't be surprised
if it ends up having something greater
than 155 domestically and something
greater than 337. you mean total or just
over the weekend just over the weekend
all right so we're talking we're talking
about a half a billion dollars in ticket
sales just over the weekend yeah yeah
and so this is or no sorry what I meant
is a collect 337 is worldwide oh okay
yeah yeah yeah 155 was the projection in
the U.S they ended up going 162
in uh domestically and Oppenheimer which
was projected to be 80 ended up getting
82 so they even went above and beyond
right so a lot of people are going to
see the movies it's almost like the
economy isn't [__] yeah it's it's crazy
um and then the Total Bond let me see if
I can find this
but but it's it's making a lot more
money than Ben Shapiro made on his
stupid radio and they added 182 million
in the international box office so if
you take 182 plus 162 that's
146 is that right let's see
but it's going to be a lot of money and
again I don't know how many points
Margot Robbie and and Ryan Gosling have
but they're yeah a lot of money because
if you weren't doing points on a movie
that's branded with Barbie you're not
doing your contract right
um 344 which was even higher because so
their projection was 337
I thought I thought it was gonna be
close to 350 is what I said yesterday so
they're at a third of a billion dollars
yeah they're at three 344 and that seems
to be the official final number for the
weekend opening box office which again
this is the biggest movie
and these are the key points that people
need to remember one this is not a
sequel
this is not part of a franchise right
this is made by an independent director
Greta Gerwig so she's not a big time
this is the first Blockbuster like big
big movie that she's made
and not only that this is the biggest
movie opening of the year and it was
filmed by a woman that's why they're mad
about women that's why they're mad
feminism that's why they're mad that's
why they're mad Peter says Marshall sell
to oh oh Mattel's gonna make a [__] so
much money I mean they already made
money off Ben Shapiro for movie specific
merch yeah that's funny oh man what a
bunch of dummies what a bunch of fascist
dummies and just to tell you be like oh
man the men aren't getting you know
they're they're due or the the men are
being treated right you know how much
respect like I was I think it was an
interview that Ryan Gosling had done and
all of them all of the men in the movie
all the guys in the movie got a
phenomenal job in terms of their role
and they all made uh Greta and a bunch
of the other and I think just all of the
other Barbie cast mates these like
embroidered uh jackets as like a nice
like little thing like thank you for for
allowing us to
enter this world with you right it
wasn't like oh we did this movie and we
deserve all the [__] praise because
without us there were it's like no dude
it's called Barbie okay right Ken is an
accessory to Barbie right there there is
no like oh we have we have Ken so we
have to have no it's like there was
Barbie and then people like hey we
should introduce another like a side
character here and that's what they make
fun of in the movie right and they they
talk about it in the in the trailer too
which is like Ken's purpose is is for
Barbie and again it's it's it's
um um it's not real Ben it's not real
speaking of merch and the toys that
they're gonna release oh [__] let me see
we've got uh there's a um seems like
there's gonna be
some Ted Cruz uh Barbie since he's so
even against them I don't know maybe I'm
wrong but here's here seems to be uh
Mattel I'm releasing Ted Cruz Barbies
introducing the Ted Cruz doll collection
that's right the senator more focused on
Barbie than his own job Mel has his own
line of toys inspired by his work you
can get Insurrection Barbie play at the
podium as you try to destroy democracy
try podcaster Barbie with your recording
studio you can promote the mega agenda
and everyone's favorite Cancun Barbie
grab your luggage and hop on a plane to
avoid your responsibility get your Ted
Cruz Barbie doll today
oh [__] they do it to themselves man I
mean they do they do it to themselves
and now Ben Shapiro is very uh he's
trying to let me let me see if I can
find the video but it looks like Ben
Shapiro is now trying to like course
correct and be like oh no no no no no no
you don't understand what I was doing
was a joke and people got offended at my
joke well you know what you know what's
funny about Ben Shapiro and daily wire
is for years they've been serious but
they finally realized the audience that
they have is a bunch of just [__]
internet trolls yeah and they think they
think all kinds of things that aren't
funny or funny so they try to do really
funny things that become unfunny and I
think that's why they kind of Keep Their
audience because they're a bunch of dumb
[__] yeah let's face it but but here is
um here's the clip you're talking about
let's see if he can so this isn't the
Barbie video this is him explaining it
yeah yeah I don't want to watch that
trash okay all right I you know what's
funny is he's dressed up as Ken in the
Barbie video too yeah yeah what a what
if I think I'm [__] here I'll ask
I'll ask the question should I dress up
like Ben Shapiro
doing the review of Barbie or should I
dress up I'm just wondering like he
wears a white shirt and a jean jacket
which is kind of like the already the
like the look that I do which is a white
shirt with like a bunny shirt you dress
up as Ken every day don't you yeah
that's what I do so now the question is
should I just dress up as [__] Ben
Shapiro doing this review for what was
that I kind of feel like I should not
the 10 version like not the movie 10
version but dress up with a jean jacket
with a white shirt and you have to you
have to at some point in this video go
actually oh don't worry I already have
hearts right okay okay good good good I
figured he had that written it here's
the clip of Ben Shapiro explaining why
his explanation of the Barbie movie that
he didn't need to explain anyways
because we can all go see it for
ourselves but he's such a chud and he's
such a baby that he had to go buy merch
buy tickets to go watch this so that he
could he could explain to his in-cell
audience of why they should hate women
let's listen so and do this review
I put out this tweet and everybody loses
their mind I mean loses their mind there
are articles about my review of this
movie
he was losing his mind about Barbie what
is he talking about he spent all this
time and all this money to lose his mind
he said Barbie was a piece of [__] it
was [__] it was
uh he said it several he said it he's
like this is [__] [__] [__] this piece
of [__] this is a terrible movie this is
anti is that the is that the most
cursing that he does ever but he bleeps
them all out so yeah but yeah that's the
most amount of cursing I've ever seen
him say ah what do you saying wait a
second reason so Ben Shapiro says the
word [__] and he bleeps it out yeah this
gives me more reason why I will never
stop cursing people tell me Tony if you
need to stop cursing you could yeah oh
man you can appeal to such a bigger
audience I'm like I don't want to be in
the same like I'll bleep out I'll bleep
out [__] yeah
but like you know [__] is one of those
things come on man but he bleeps out
[__] so many times in this video but not
in this video but in his review video
well his review video is probably beep
that's all I'm saying you know what I
mean
um but he's he's bitching here that
people are losing their minds we weren't
losing your our minds we're laughing at
you Ben we're laughing at you because
you're so pathetic but keep going keep
going with your delusion in sources as
diverse as Newsweek NBC News The Daily
Beast everyone's covering the fact that
I did not like this movie and that I
made a video in which I herodically
Oppenheimer the Barbie materials I take
like a match and I like the Barbie stuff
on fire and this apparently is terrible
no it can't be the reaction to me
burning a Barbie car with like a Barbie
and candidate is like the reaction of
the Islamic world when someone Burns a
Quran in Sweden
oh Jesus Christ this guy with his stupid
[__] analogy is so ridiculous man no
one thinks that yeah no one everyone
looked at you and like why did you buy
this [__] to burn it it only gave them
money yeah that is exactly what I mean
the only reason the the main reason I'm
gonna make fun of him is the fact that
he is a 39 year old man
[Laughter]
who said he was forced
by his producers to go see this movie oh
man even though we all know that it's
hate hate clickbait and engagement and
he went to the movie even though he said
I didn't want to go and they forced me
and then he did a movie review about it
and then he bought these materials
bought the toys lit them on fire
this is the reality of the situation is
that he is a little [__] and he doesn't
like the fact that people are making fun
of him and now he's trying to course
correct and say no no no no this was all
a parody and I lit it on fire like
Oppenheimer because get it it's like a
bomb and an explosion so he doesn't know
what parody is then apparently yeah Oh
that's oh he doesn't know what funny
that's what he said he's like I
perotically did it mocking it yeah as
like Oppenheimer the bomb but that's the
part that he doesn't understand people
aren't making fun of him because they're
upset no one is okay no one is pissed
off that he did it we're all making fun
of him because again he's a nearly 40
year old man
who just made a 40 nearly 43 Minute
review
that was all of him hating on the movie
and he bought these materials and lit
them on fire like he could have done so
many other things probably spent time
with his kids
if they care about him I'm sure he took
his daughters to the movie and they
loved it I mean I am I almost I almost
bet you I almost bet you that he took
his [__] daughters to this movie and
he sat and watched it with them and he
sat and watched it with him like oh this
is a great movie well all this [__]
about Barbie and all this [__] 43
minute video and all this [__] where
he's like no it was a joke and all this
that's all [__] fake it's all fake
for their little [__] bro ships that
they have on the internet these people
these incels that hate women and they
have to feed that hate that's all
they're doing is just feeding hate
they're just feeding hatred for women
that's all he's doing but let's let's
see if he can tell us how he's not funny
it's totally crazy I don't even like wow
guys wow I mean there's an article in
NBC nbcnews.com the internet is roasting
Ben Shapiro for hate watching Barbie
ball dressed like Ken apparently being
dressed like Ken now amounts to you wear
black jeans and a black shirt the
question was whether I had purposefully
worn that outfit to the Barbie movie no
I hadn't seen it guys that's just what
people tend to wear a lot it's like a
you know like a black T-shirt and black
I didn't realize this was like a rare
and unique bird it was like it was like
a it's like some sort of rare pheasant
in the wild to wear a black pair of
jeans and a black shirt
when I go out yeah I actually don't
think that he intentionally did this but
I think he's mortified that he
accidentally dressed up yeah no no
totally I don't think that he did I
don't think that he had the foresight
and I'm actually really surprised that
he didn't be like oh yeah actually I did
do that as a joke right I I hadn't
watched that clip or at least he's
really upset that they caught on to that
and he's like no no no no no and that's
and that's why is he's upset because
they think he dressed as Ken and it
wasn't his real idea yeah exactly and so
that's that's the thing is you've got
this guy who has four kids okay four
kids he's got a wife who he can't make
wet uh or get wet or may come or
whatever you want to say that's his
words not ours we didn't say that ever
since ever since but let me tell you
ever since he released this video oh
baby I am digging through the receipts
I'm going through his [__] I'm pulling a
blast onion the Glass Onion review I'm
do I'm pulling up the tear on the
Prairie with Gina Carano I'm pulling up
all the [__] not only is he a failed
screenwriter he's a failed critic too
failed critic failed producer Tony let
me tell you oh my God that look people
people who are part of my patreon uh get
ready because this thing's about to be
[__] wild the things I'm gonna I'm
gonna make fun of Ted Cruz momentarily
I'm gonna make fun of Ginger Gates
momentarily but then I'm Really Gonna
dive into [__] Ben Shapiro I'm gonna
pull it all out I'm pulling the movie
reviews out I'm pulling the movie
production out I'm pulling everything
because this guy believes oh actually
I'm a a movie critic and the real uh the
real way in which you make a movie about
a doll is to just make them plastic and
not have any emotions because I mean
they're inanimate objects in the sense
of they don't actually have a
Consciousness or any sort of persona
shut down oh my God how many dolls do
you think this game's got
probably as many probably as many blow
up dolls as fellatio blow oh okay do you
think they look like Trump and they got
their mouths I think they do they're
always some of them some of them are
mechanical you know
although although in Min Shapiro on the
DeSantis train until he's not and then I
honestly don't know oh uh I have not
followed up with like experience his
with his predictions and stuff it seems
like he would be on the DeSantis train
then and then tell his audience how
stupid it would to be this yeah
speaking of stupid ideas we gotta go
over this we only have 15 minutes left
and I know this is going to take 15
minutes
Elon Musk decides that he spent 44
billion dollars on a brand yeah on a
logo because that's truly basically what
he bought because this is just Clear
Blue Sky type stuff right
44 million dollars and he decides you
know what [__] that we're gonna call it
X which
hell has a lot of problems behind it but
here's his here's his tweet here it says
if a
if a good enough X logo is posted
tonight I will make it go live worldwide
I think this is the best X art that is
presented that represents Twitter
nowadays
um to be quite honest with you the stars
and bars is probably the best one that
represents Twitter
hell man but he is gonna try to change
it to X now I'm going to show the
audience here that yes he has changed it
to 2x here's the uh here's here's the
top of the page see that there that's
the new stupid [__] logo and pointed
out that it looks like a razor blade
cutting a line of cocaine which yes yes
that is true now here's also what if
people don't 100 the 100 by uh hard on
crowd should love that by the way oh
yeah of course of course yeah
um but uh
so click click the link yeah
all right so this is the story
of this logo okay
this logo wasn't created by a designer
it wasn't made in-house so no one at
Twitter or X or whatever created this
thing right the story behind this x is
that there's a guy who's an Elon simp
and he had a podcast that was all about
Elon and all of his companies oh yeah
and it was yeah and uh he he made a logo
that was like similar to the logo you
see now
and it's all it's based on monotype
special alphabets four okay like I even
have it here in the so it's like a font
in other words it's a font I mean this
is also something that you get from the
Unicode which is another font as well
which has been around for a long time
so first off the logo was not designed
by anyone
in in this in the last weekend
this logo was designed years ago and two
different two different uh rounds
but this guy is claiming this is the
actual quote from this Elon Fanboy that
I said this is the logo I designed and
if Elon Musk wants it he can have it for
free well from what I understand this
guy who had the logo bought the font and
like slightly modified it in its shape
and size and then reposted it and said
okay I designed it
you didn't design [__] the the amount of
laziness and theft that is happening
here as I said I said designed
on his lazy stance it's totally on a
brand the logo wasn't a logo that they
made it was an existing font character
an existing font character tweeted it
this morning I think that character yeah
like you tweet like you tweeted it up
here see that yeah exactly yeah
it's just one of those things where
where it's
the
the right
have no good designers
they have no good creativity
and it's all because
they have no empathy good design good
creativity comes from empathy they are
inherently tied together because it
requires you as a designer
to have empathy for the user and
understand their situation
or else you would just make something
and say well if you don't like it too
[__] bad and that's a totally fine
approach if you want it
but to understand that's kind of what I
do I'm like I'm gonna say what I want to
say in two parts well you have empathy
towards situations well let's talk about
them now you have no empathy for Nazis
and fascists no which is which is
different which is different so as a
designer when I look at this I said this
is a piece of [__] because it's not that
somebody designed this it's that it's a
stolen font type character X right from
a from some from from an actual design
firm that designed it years ago right
and Elon and there's a difference
there's a difference between inspiration
and stealing too yeah and some people
say like oh you know copying is the
highest form of flattery no no that's
that's just theft that is theft right
there right and as a designer I or or
who you know monotype owns it so if they
come forward to say ah this is this is
like okay you know what this is like
this is like vanilla ice
saying how his song Ice Ice Baby because
yeah he's like but my song is
and their song is like the fact that uh
Vanilla Ice said that which who by the
way do you know the villain ice owns
that song now
he bought it it was cheaper to buy David
Bowie and queen's song than it was to
pay the fees so he actually owns the
right so he makes [__] Bank off that
right but the X the the way in which
someone's like oh no it's completely
different it's the same way that
uh that Vanilla Ice was like oh no no
it's a completely different beat by this
one uh part of the song well the right
wing the right wing has a history of
stealing X's right yeah stealing X's for
their fascism they really do I'll show
you a few examples here I'll show you a
few examples of how they steal an X
um to uh as their symbolism and everyone
knows the the famous Nazi uh swastika
but a lot of people don't know that that
emblem was even stolen that X was even
stolen so they they identify and steal
X's all the time everywhere they take
those symbols away from the cultures or
groups that they're originally part of
right on purpose so that that original
group doesn't have any more right right
because now when people when people look
at that that symbol in India they go oh
my God why is that swastika like what
the Nazis and they're like no no you
don't understand
Nazis stole it from them right and
repurposed it so that they could use as
a symbol of hate as the actual purpose
to repurpose it for hate instead of the
actual I mean they do this all the time
that's why they're called moms for
Liberty they're not actually for Liberty
yeah they're not really for Liberty
that's not what they are when that when
the Nazis call themselves National
socialists they weren't actually
socialist they they were pretending to
be so that you wouldn't think they were
the other another uh uh ruthman got uh
she she gives this uh great
um um view of it X has been you know
fascist love the X like crazy and and
she points out the Twitter XX conjures
quote starting from zero right and the
ability to erase history and start time
over again and that's what elon's doing
here he's starting over because you
because you when you were texting back
and forth I've thought that this x thing
I actually still believe it that they're
doing it right now because of the
threads
um he's probably and and I I think
you've brought this up before he's
brought up changing the name and [__]
yeah and and uh emulating he's been
wanting to make it this x app the ever X
the everything app like right right
again
it's WeChat WeChat that's what it yes
and that's all it is but the only reason
that WeChat works is because it is uh
integrated with the Chinese government
the Chinese government is bought in the
only way that Twitter or X could ever be
to the scale that it is because Elon
there's an interview he just did
recently and the videos out there on
Twitter and he basically says like oh
yeah well X will have will handle half
half
50 percent or some large number as he
later said of digital Financial
transactions they want to be a banking
Institute no not weed chat yeah yeah
someone's high in the chat here
someone's trying to live chat no yeah
you're smoking and and hearing we chat
but that's the reason the only reason
that WeChat is successful is because
they got government buy-in from the
beginning
good luck trying to get government
buy-in now in a private app because if
that were to happen
all of these right wing idiots would be
like oh no big government they got their
hand in the pot that out of this and
that no longer free speech
that's what they don't understand
they're like oh yeah wechats great app
it's got everything connected it's also
got the [__] government inside it's
watching all of what they're doing right
these right-wing idiots don't understand
that oh it's the Deep state is that what
you're saying oh man that's crazy it's a
[__] deep statement well here's what
Rory says where he said fascists love
that they're starting over again
um as the Roman numeral for 10 x
featured in propaganda honoring a decade
of fascism and this like Expedition
catalog so I I you know what I should
reach out to Ruth and see if she wants
to come on and talk about it yes this
acts as a symbol for fascism because uh
elon's obsessed with X right he's
obsessed with it yeah I mean he named
his son X he named his SpaceX logos X
the neural Link logo looks like an X
uh he tried to call paypalx.com before
he got shoved out from the board uh I
mean the guy is obsessed with X like he
like he's owned x.com for over two
decades
trying to integrate this somewhere and
he finally is able to do it and the way
that I and I had a tweet yesterday which
I was like it's very un it's very very
easy to understand the motivation that
Elon has the reason
that he is doing this whole Rebrand and
refresh of X and x.com and here's the
logo X and all this [__] is because Elon
can't ever claim
that he created Twitter
right he has to only be able to claim
created X which is a building block
which is [__] which is [__] so
he can't ever see us change the logo
just like he never created Tesla you
know like these are all things that he
he did not create well that's the other
thing he acts like he created Twitter
spaces too like what the [__] are you
talking about man that was long before
you Twitter spaces is a copy off of uh
clubhouse right which was something that
was during the pandemic audio spaces
it's not new now it's radio copied it
off of them it's radio and and you
didn't do that Elon you didn't do spaces
now I think he really was you know if he
wanted to go with X and then X logo I
think he really missed the Mark here
because this this is another appropriate
X logo that was submitted to Elon
um x marks the spot right this really
shows
um um the X I don't know what it kind of
looks familiar I don't know maybe Elon
can elaborate but this x I thought this
x looked uh pretty good
um but now it gets Morehead said am I
too late for
my submission and it seems like he
misspelled
for there until you really um
figure out right take a closer look so
this I think I think Elon really missed
the Mark here and if there's any
Engineers
do not miss the mark though right that
is true like when does Elon ever
Implement an idea totally didn't have
the money shot when he had the money
shot right in front of him like you you
he could have made more money just by
throwing the 44 billion dollars in
putting competent people in and now he's
like hey you know what I really want to
do even though money is like very tight
around here I want to split the
advertising Revenue with other people to
incentivize them to stay but not
everyone's going to be able to do it
because it only has to happen with big
accounts that require this many
Impressions so if you want a little
taste of maybe something you got to buy
in and pay me eight dollars or eleven
dollars a month depending on when you do
how how frequently you want it to be uh
big Steph is on the porn counter she
says um does that set the poor encounter
back to zero I really think it does it
does because we showed two big old
dildos because people are asking like oh
well there's if it's no longer Twitter
videos is it XVideos oh and if you were
to Google videos
there's a lot of porn on Twitter I'm not
gonna lie yeah yeah but it's funny you
know look at that look the Bots aren't a
problem anymore the porn the child the
child pornography is it a problem on
Twitter according to Elon anymore it is
a problem on X now though yeah it is
oh it's so stupid so I wasn't a couple
weeks ago I said wouldn't it be funny if
threads destroyed Twitter
and Twitter didn't exist anymore but we
still called all posts on the internet a
tweet
um I I don't I don't have a crystal ball
here I literally do not have one but I'm
telling you I said I we can go back and
we can pull the tape but I said a couple
weeks ago I said wouldn't it be funny it
went when threads started to come out
it's like wouldn't it be funny this
destroys Twitter and Twitter just goes
you know by the wayside and and every
Post online now it's called the Tweet
but their Twitter doesn't exist anymore
I may get my wish and Elon delivered it
right directly to me I don't know what
to tell you what am I saying I mean they
don't I it yeah it's gonna be
interesting to watch how they re-
re-label these things that we have for
the last 15 years or so because that's
really when the company started you know
but like
even if you want to say in the last like
since like 2009 2010 when like you know
more and more general population got it
like that's less 13 years 14 years or so
that people have been using this app
they're like oh yeah tweet it just
tweeted me just DM me right like what
are we gonna call DMS right DMX I don't
know like no you can't do that DMX I
know it's tough I know I mean it just
seems like a huge legal right it's cool
that he's got himself well again I'm not
going to stop calling it Twitter oh yeah
no they're tweeting I mean I saw some
very good comparisons like someone like
myself from Chicago I will always know
it has the Sears Tower okay Sears Tower
that's right you'll never be able to you
can't tell me it's a Wills Tower it's
the Sears Tower yeah and people are like
this is exactly that situation you are
going to tell me right now that this is
called x no no no dude this is [__] you
this is this Twitter business this is
you trying to read it to Twitter or from
Twitter to X we're not playing [__]
Sears town he's literally myspacing
himself right in front of all of us
which also if you wanted to make the
argument yeah if you wanted to make the
argument and feel free for people to go
take this
think about this
X okay
don't call me Twitter that's not my
preferred name my preferred name is X
equator's got pronouns now so I prefer
pronoun my preferred name don't call me
don't call me Twitter uh oh my God so
now you got to think okay so you wonder
if I wonder if Twitter is going to be a
slur on Twitter I don't know I'm just
saying like if you want to use that
that's a free one for you all feel free
to go out there and take that one you'll
piss off all the Sims with little dicks
speaking of Simply little dicks I want
to show you something Gabe Sanchez from
one of your buddies
um before we leave this is a really
short video uh apparently said Gorka
here Seb your buddy is showing everyone
how he has a little penis watch
enough with the Gay Pride Flags how
about this flag that's pretty gay
uh Seb telling the entire world look I
got a small penis that's hilarious what
a [__] it is it is uh
I I had to show that they gave Sanchez
before we leave the show we're running
out of time everybody make sure to smash
the like button as you leave smash the
like button as you leave hit subscribe
on the Tony Michaels podcast you're not
going to want to miss a single [__]
episode Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific live live
live you can even watch it live on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels go follow
me on Facebook at the Tony Michaels you
can watch live there you can also watch
live on Twitch thank you for all the
twitch folks who have resubscribed this
morning and subscribe using their Amazon
Prime account go to twitch.tv slash the
Tony Michaels and you can follow us for
free
but if you have a Prime account you can
link it to your
if you have an Amazon Prime account you
can link it to your Twitch account and
give us that one free subscription and
don't forget to re-subscribe every
single month go to the tonymichaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com the
directions are like the fourth fourth
one down Gabe you probably have a what
was that coming I'm sure right I gotta
what was that on the Barbie movie uh if
you haven't seen we'll watch the uh the
the latest one tomorrow on the show but
I just did one on Margaret Taylor green
and fellatio blow and that's right
and then I'm working on Barbie right now
and I might have another one on Rhonda
santis three for the next couple days
so go to what was that show.com or go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez that's
patreon.com
Sanchez check out those what was that
and while you're on patreon check out my
page two at the Tony Michaels game we
had a great conversation with the
[__] van last night we're working on
this project it's called the round table
of democracy we're all gonna work
together because I tell the audience all
the time they need to engage in their
democracy now we're going to work on
Gathering the tools to engage in your
democracy together we're going to do it
as a collective on my patreon so go to
patreon.com
be watching for details and
conversations this week that we are
going to be having with the [__] fam
on patreon to figure out how we're going
to make this work and how we're gonna
provide the tools
for everyone here in the audience at the
Tony Michaels podcast to engage in their
democracy to save their democracy from
autocracy just as you should every
single weekday download each and every
episode on Apple's Spotify and Google
and come watch us live live live live
live live live live live live live live
same time same place tomorrow
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon
well Ben Shapiro went to the movies to
watch Barbie and he's pretty upset about
it so I figured I'd write this too and
try to cheer him up I call it the legend
of Barbie and Ben
little Ben grabbed a pen and nobody
[Music]
said that red face then white nuggets
it's a little ahead about to explode
surrounded by those middle Edge mamas
shaking like a leaf and scared to death
what's he to do with all the madness
when Lord knows he can't get him with
Loretta
Miranda sure has crossed the line
trans Barbie she drove him out of his
mind he sat there human while beating
off again and so goes the legend of
Barbie
he's screaming boycott he's gotta get a
handle on all of this far left Chinese
propaganda he burned all his Barbies
with her Jeep and pins and so does the
legend of Barbie
feelings
[Music]